the Joe Rogan experience I know you
liked a lot of aspects of living up
there but what's like is there one thing
that really stands out one thing would
definitely be the autonomy the
independence I think is this a natural
need that humans have you watch a little
baby when they learn to crawl
they start separating from their mother
a little bit then they start to learn to
stand up but they're still holding on to
the wall
then they start taking their first steps
and it's like wow I can stand on my own
feet you know they get all excited and
start running along before very long
mm-hmm and I think we just need that
feeling of independence some people more
than others
but it's the same basic thing for me
it's just like to be out there totally
independent on my own nobody else is
gonna help me if I have a problem
you know if I'm up on a mountain and I
don't have a satellite following me I
got to be able to walk back to my camp I
have to be able to there's literally no
choice right and just to have that
degree of responsibility mmm that in
modern society you don't have you can't
have that degree of responsibility in
modern society for yourself you can't
have that level of independence it's
standing on your own is it hard for you
to like come to a place like LA like
what is it weird like what is it what's
the feeling when you're driving on the
405 from the airport headed over to the
studio you had to be you have to be like
why the [ __ ] would anybody live here no
no no I find it fascinating it's it's
interesting because it's a different
environment I mean I'm very curious
about the way people live everywhere but
I do find myself realizing why I don't
live in a big city you know yeah I find
it very really nice interesting me
sleeping have a shower it's like well
this is cold water toilet a toy I don't
we have oil to the toilets here did you
use one yet yeah tell but they built
them too high I'm used to squatting and
oh squad
you get a squatty potty know what that
is no they basically yeah it's like a
thing that they put underneath the
toilet you put your feet on oh yeah sort
of put your butt in the right position
I'll ask I'll ask the front desk they're
going tonight I don't think they will
say yes but that's what you're supposed
to have right looks supposed to be in a
position where you're squatting that's
the natural position for humans to [ __ ]
it works for me that's another thing I
like about it out there okay there's the
autonomy that independence is very
important and I think a lot of people
are missing that and that's why they're
attracted to to learn something about
that life but also just like I said when
you do these basic things to be taking a
crap it could be taking a shower
whatever in in a different way out in
nature I mean you can't a lot of people
can't bathe outside they want to they
don't have the privacy or this but when
that's your your normal thing I mean it
becomes a totally natural thing and it's
like very healthy and it's beautiful
like it kind of you're out there looking
at mountains all around in nature a
little Tweety birds flying by while
you're bathing you know you're not
sealed off in some little fiberglass
cubicle hmm yeah I did everything yeah
it's it's a 100 percent different way of
living life and your perceptions change
your senses change in the modern world
there's a lot of extraneous noise and
imagery that we're filtering out all the
time you can't pay attention to
everything did you ever get injured
while you're up there yeah yeah but you
can't pay attention to everything I'll
get to it okay you can't pay attention
to everything so you're filtering stuff
out all the time right right and when
you're out in that environment it's very
quiet you're not getting inundated with
all of this extraneous noise and you're
instead of filtering you're tuning in
you're really tuning in like one little
bird that hasn't been around the valley
flies through I'll know it I'll hear it
Wow hey that was a pine grosbeak I
haven't heard one of those for a while
mm-hmm you're paying attention to
everything
and that's really different it changes
it changes the way you think there's a
feeling that you get when you're in the
real wilderness like particularly we did
some hunting on Prince of Wales yeah and
you know when you're you're out there
it's raining rains every day hmm
and there's this feeling of beautiful
isolation like you're really isolated I
mean you're really alone there's no you
don't see anything you don't hear
anything and there's this indifference
that Nature has towards you that's
really humbling it's like it puts you in
your place yeah
humans need that they need to be put in
their place like I always say that some
of the nicest people live near mountains
and live near the ocean I think the
reason being is the ocean just lets you
know hey [ __ ] look at that you ain't
[ __ ] look at that water so you can't you
can't survive there and did knowing that
there's something right there that you
can't survive in it's like a there's it
checks you a little bit the mountains
check you that the sheer beauty and the
vastness like if you know you're looking
out at the Continental Divide and you
see the the Rocky Mountains it's like
it's humbling it's humbling on the one
hand you feel really strong being able
to do what you're doing there but on the
other hand you feel really small yeah
really vulnerable really insignificant
[Applause]